c'est à la ferme des clos à bonnel dans
le sud yvelines que le candidat a l'air
m aux élections régionales en île de
france laurent san martin a fait son
premier déplacement de campagne vendredi
5 mars
normalement dans un monde normal on
aurait dû se rendre avec grand plaisir
comme chaque année au salon de
l'agriculture
voilà cette année nous avons fait le
choix évidemment d'aller malgré tout à
la rencontre de ces professionnels de
ces agriculteurs et c'est pas plus mal
finalement un mal pour un bien
nous ne sommes pas au salon porte de
versailles mais nous sommes directement
dans les exploitations
c'est mieux on comprend mieux la réalité
du terrain et c'est je crois la façon la
plus sincère d'échangé dans cette ferme
plusieurs producteurs se sont rassemblés
certains même issu de reconversion
professionnelle apiculteurs houblonnière
maraîchers ici on cohabite s'est
accompagnée de rohr berger députés de ce
territoire que le candidat est venu je
crois que c'était important de venir
rencontrer dialoguer échanger pour voir
comment plusieurs modèles peuvent
coexister et voir comment demain la
région elle peut être plus son soutien
plus son impulsion aussi d'un
accompagnement à la fois financiers mais
aussi à l'accompagnement montage des
projets qui peuvent exister ici le
candidat entend donc s'il est élu
encourager ce genre d'initiatives mais
note que de grandes disparités existent
dans la région
il faut pas oublier que dans cette
région il est aussi beaucoup
d'inégalités beaucoup de difficultés et
que notre priorité
demain à la région ile de france c'est
évidemment favorisé et libérer tout le
potentiel incroyable de cette région
mais aussi enfin résoudre les
innombrables inégalités qui se sont
creusés pendant la crise mais qui existe
est malheureusement bien avant après
avoir visité la ferme des clos le
candidat et la députée se sont rendus
dans d'autres exploitations